en pleine crise sanitaire économique
sociale ou les suppressions d'emplois à
la détresse du personnel soignant des
enseignants et d'une grande partie de la
population sont devenus la norme
il ya quand même certaines priorités
qu'il faut pas oublier ça fait soixante
dix ans que le salon doré du palais de
l'elysée n'avait pas été rénovée c'est
scandaleux
en plus c'est les journées du patrimoine
et il faut bien que les français
puissent avoir le droit de profiter du
luxe et du face de la résidence de leur
président bah oui emmanuel macron le
répète souvent on n'ose pas décidé ces
travaux alors que c'est notre devoir
pas sûr que les gilets jaunes qui
manifestent depuis bientôt deux ans
contre la politique du gouvernement
considère la rénovation du palais de
l'elysée comme un devoir mais bon c'est
pas le sujet au moins maintenant le
président pourra faire ses allocutions
télévisées sans ressentir l'inconfort
que ressent le mona dont le trône est
devenu quelque peu poussiéreux je suis
désolé c'est important quand on voit à
quel point les éléments revivent comme
les fleurs et les nymphes ressorte ça
s'est complètement transformée à bas
avec quinze mille feuilles d'or de 0,2
microns d'épaisseur ce qui fait environ
390 grammes c'est sûr que ça s'est
transformé
ils ont pas mis un coup de feu breizh
ces gens sont très sérieux ces emplois
et ce savoir faire français permettent
de projeter l'excellence française à
l'étranger
tout à fait d'accord mohammed bin salman
actuellement se ronge les ongles au fond
du couloir terrassé par l'envi en
novembre 2018 alors que des millions de
personnes se mettaient à défiler dans
les grandes villes de france pour les
premiers actes d gilet jaune la première
dame non plus n'était pas laisser mettre
la pression
rénovation du mobilier de l'elysée pour
plusieurs millions d'euros et bien pas
de chez casto la table basse on avait
l'impression que l'elysée était devenue
une forteresse qui se protéger de
l'extérieur on va aller j'ai épuré il
faut de la lumière
c'est vrai qu'il fait un peu sombre et
la vaisselle à 500000 euros pareil c'est
la moindre des choses
on va pas manger dans des assiettes en
carton un dîner d'état c'est pas un
pique nique sur l'autoroute a7 je
rappelle quand même qui a encore le
temps fort de brégançon y avait même pas
de piscine c'est scandaleux
et même si après avoir eu sa piscine le
président dans un bain de foule admet
préférer la maire c'est son droit
y a que les imbéciles qui ne changent
pas d'avis donc rénover le salon doré de
l'elysée c'est un peu la base du swag
même si ça plaît pas à tout le monde
bah non mais je suis pas d'accord non
neuf cent trente mille euros
tu en sais rien 130000 euros vivre